what's going on guys this is rob and
this video is brought to you by osborne
industries so osborne industries is
looking for young people who are
interested in applying to their research
and development summer internship
program at osborne industries they use
technology and the power of teamwork to
discover new ways to prevent and
overcome the world's most significant
healthcare challenges their corporate
consumer health medical devices and
pharmaceutical teams leverage data real
world insights and creative minds to
make life-changing healthcare products
and medicine they're disrupting outdated
healthcare ecosystems and infusing them
with transformative ideas to help people
thrive throughout every stage of their
lives at osborne industries your
internship contributions will change the
future of health in all the best ways
and you'll change too now if you guys
are interested in this program make sure
you check the link down in the
description and before you write it off
just keep in mind
you may be something of a scientist
yourself but getting into the video we
recently learned or at least i recently
learned after i'd been out for a week
sick what a great way to start the new
year though we're apparently getting the
amazing spider-man 3 with andrew
garfield and in reality this just makes
good sense right it just makes good
sense i mean we all kind of knew what
was coming right there has never been a
time in the history of andrew's
career as spider-man when people were
more excited to see him as spider-man
then during no way home like i don't
know about you guys but one i feel like
all those videos out there they're like
the reaction videos when he jumps
through the portal when ned leads opens
it and then like rips off his mask and
reveals that he's like andrew garfield i
feel like half of those views are me
[Laughter]
but you guys are seeing those videos
right like he rips off the mask he
reveals it is andrew garfield and the
crowd pops everybody goes nuts right and
i think a lot of that was based on just
the fact that it was possibly true
but it also may not have been true it
was just murky enough to not really know
whether or not it was actually going to
happen a lot of people said they knew it
was going to happen but at the end of
the day none of us really did right i
mean there were like some screenshots
that were out there and i remember there
was a video that was made where they
were like no there's no way anybody cgi
the face of andrew garfield on him that
is actually andrew garfield on that set
piece in that video right i mean we saw
those kinds of things but we didn't
actually know what was gonna happen
until we saw him in the movie and that
when he was there it just kind of
completed it right it just it sort of
gave us what it was that we wanted which
was the trinity of live-action
spider-man right you start with toby you
went into andrew then you go into tom
and it just sort of gave us everything
that we were hoping for it was it was
perfect right and even the scene to
follow when they're like all swinging
around all that kind of stuff it was an
absolutely amazing scene and so a third
spider-man film just is it's it's too
good of an opportunity to pass up
because what it would do is it would
complete the trinity of
trinity films for each one of the guys
right toby got his three tom got his
three now andrew gets his three and he
gets to ride off into the sunset it's
cool right just sort of end it with this
third movie and that's it right and then
wherever we end up going with spider-man
from here is wherever we end up going
right tom holland gets his new trinity
of movies that trinity ends tom holland
walks away and then you get miles more
alice who takes over the role of
spider-man in the mcu right done and
done right that's that's basically it
but the question we have to ask here is
that with this third amazing spider-man
movie
what is this movie going to look like
and in my mind there's only ever one of
two story lines that i want to see play
out or at least see them borrow from one
of these two story lines the first of
these is a recent story that's actually
called spider-man spider shadow by chip
zodarski and in fact we're doing a video
on that at comics explain i'm just going
to call like andrew garfield spider-man
kills the marvel universe because i
don't know about you guys those of you
guys who are watching this and you read
comics sometimes i'll take mcu
characters and like put them two
characters in the comics right like the
spider-man comics they'll be like that's
tom holland and like it just makes
things more interesting to me right just
makes it more fascinating the other one
is actually the character of assassins
spiderman we'll talk about him in a
minute to focus on spider shadow and
again we're not going to go super in
depth into this that's what comics
explained us for but for spiders shadow
this is a recent story this actually
kind of a what if story regarding the
events that came out of secret wars and
went into the spider-man comics right so
one of the things we talked about here
before is the nature of secret wars
largely that conversation has been
confined to speculation on like what the
movie will look like when the russo said
they wanted to make a secret wars film
but the thing about this is that during
that story spider-man got the venom
symbiote for the first time but didn't
realize it was a venom symbiote and it
was just kind of a suit that he wore it
wasn't until he got back to earth and
started experiencing these nightmares
where he was fighting this kind of
symbiotic entity and at the same time
the symbiote was taking his body while
he was sleeping going out into the world
and doing things that you realize the
symbiote was basically nefarious so for
those of you guys who saw toby
spider-man 3 where basically he got the
symbiote and like the symbiote was
taking him out and doing stuff and he
became like a darker version of himself
that was very similar to what happened
in the comics not shot for shot but in
terms of the form and function it's
pretty identical and so of course peter
parker got rid of the venom symbiote and
then of course the venom symbiote bonded
itself to eddie brock and then you got
venom in the classic sense the story of
spider shadow actually goes a different
direction and it basically answers the
question what if peter parker not only
kept the venom symbiote but actually
embraced that darker side and so he
actually ends up killing his sinister
six for the most part and it gets pretty
crazy i mean because it's spider-man he
doesn't stay evil and basically he's
redeemed the venom symbiotes removed
from him and then you know they saved
and so on and so forth what you would
normally expect with like the the prized
possession of marvel comics right like
the incorruptable spider-man so again
the story basically ended on a more
positive note but the character of
assassin's spider-man was not that way
so assassin spider-man was introduced
during the events of spider-verse and
spider-verse of course is a story where
dealt with a big team up from all these
different spider-man from across the
multiverse but assassin's spider-man
only had an origin story and then jumped
straight into the main spider-verse
event where he died shortly after but
the origin story of assassins spider-man
is that basically after peter parker
gained his powers in the way he
traditionally does but after losing the
people that were closest to him he
basically decided all the villains had
to die that the only way to basically
fix crime was to essentially kill at
least the most notable super villains
and then it went from his own super
villains into like actually other
villains across the world and he
actually ended up making what looked
like a utopian new york in a lot of ways
right because dead villains cannot
commit crimes and so because of that he
basically became like a killer right he
was a spider-man who killed villains now
i'm not saying that the amazing
spider-man 3 has to be one or the other
in the most true to comic sense that's
not really what i'm advocating here more
often than not you will never really
hear me say i want to see a perfect
adaptation of a comic in film form
largely because it would be kind of
boring to me i already know how the
story plays out i read it when it came
out
sure it'd be cool to see some elements
of that story in film form but it's not
a necessity to me it's something that
i've learned to appreciate the longer
that i've watched comic book movies but
the thing about this is it'd be very
easy for sony to borrow heavily from
either one of those and give us that
darker version of andrew garfield
because it's what we were told in
spider-man no way home that andrew
garfield following the death of gwen
stacy became dark right he became pretty
brutal and i would go as far as to say
there were some illusions that he
probably killed a guy or two and so
having that being a major plot of the
movie itself would really stand in lieu
of a villain one of the things about
american society is we're sort of
obsessed with like the bad guy right
like the tangible bad guy there has to
always be a bad guy there has to always
be a villain right there has to be
someone dressed all in black right some
living manifestation of the macabre that
we can point to and be like see that's
the villain right i mean as americans we
don't really know how to function if
there's not an obvious bad guy right we
just kind of break down and really start
to panic right it just creates this
existential crisis but i think in lieu
of some kind of traditional villain like
doctor octopus or chameleon or somebody
like that instead the main villain is
andrew himself that the film while you
will have like some adventures and
you'll have like you know action
sequences and things like that the
overarching theme of the movie is that
andrew is experiencing this
inner turmoil right on one hand the
death of gwen stacy happened because of
the green goblin the fact that he could
have killed the green goblin before that
and gwen stacy would have been alive if
he'd gotten to her faster if this had
happened if that had happened right all
these things that he beats himself over
the head about that he could have done
beforehand that would have saved gwen
stacy's life right this is what he
struggles with all this is just kind of
coming together right this giant melting
pot losing uncle ben losing gwen stacy
all those things merging together to
create this sort of perfect storm of if
i had done things differently i wouldn't
have lost uncle ben i wouldn't have lost
gwen stacy that's one of the big
differences between peter parker as it
was played by toby mcguire and peter
parker as it was played by andrew i get
the andrew garfield movies were not
necessarily as well received as the toby
movies but one they were darker and they
were more visceral that in the movies
with tobey maguire they were more
lighthearted and the reason for that is
because outside of blade in the late
1990s comic book movies were relatively
new at least in the form of successful
comic book franchises i mean you could
go all the way back to the 80s with like
howard the duck and go back even further
if you want to go with the old george
reeves superman movies right but for
this point having like the x-men
franchise the spider-man franchise it
was new water that was being tread here
and so having a more light-hearted
approach to things having a tone for
spider-man that felt more like how you
imagined spider-man being as opposed to
dark visceral gritty stories it just
made good sense but by the time andrew
garfield came around there was perfect
opportunity to give us darker spider-man
stories and i think that's what made his
story so compelling in a lot of ways
that's what would make this compelling
but i digress the important thing here
is that what tony mcguire would
contribute as maybe something akin to
the learning curve or the nature of life
andrew garfield contributes to personal
failures and that just constantly weighs
on him and then it eats at him and
that's his source of darkness that's how
he became that darker version of himself
and the longer this goes on the less
time he takes to cope with this the more
that darkness takes over him so that
description that he gave in spider-man
no way home when he was telling toby and
he was telling tom when he was standing
up there and they met tom for the first
time and he said i became darker right
after the death of gwyn i became darker
i became more brutal i stopped i stopped
pulling my punches i started hurting
people right like when he's saying that
you're watching that happen over the
course of the movie and you're seeing
how easy it is to succumb to that and i
think in all honesty that works sure
it's not a traditional villain but what
we lack in the form of some physical
force out there that he has to fight is
made up for intangibility and
relatability because you've been there
before and i've been there before every
single one of us has at some point of
online lost something right it's the
nature of this life that we live as you
get older things just get taken from you
yes it sucks and it never gets easier
but we've all experienced that and we've
all found different ways of coping with
it some of us found constructive ways to
cope with our struggles some of us found
destructive ways to cope with our
struggles and maybe found a way to bring
ourselves back but the important thing
is we've all been in that position where
somewhere along the line we felt like we
lost everything and being able to see
someone like spider-man who's supposed
to be this incorruptible person this
person where the harshness of life never
really hits him as hard because somehow
or another as a hero he always finds a
way back to see him basically fail is
huge because what it does is it
completes the nature of gwen stacy's
death the reason why i say that is that
in the comics right when gwen stacy died
her death was landmark right i mean when
i say landmark i mean had never happened
before in that capacity and in fact the
the death of flash's wife iris west
happened after the death of gwen stacy
that's how big it was right never up to
that point in the history of comic book
publishing
the history of comic book publishing had
a hero failed in such a spectacular way
that their love interest died not only
had that never happened before it had
never happened because of the actions of
the hero himself in the andrew garfield
movie it happened a little bit different
he shot his webbing and he was just a
hair too late right in her head smacked
the ground and that was the end of gwen
in the comics peter basically broke her
neck he shot his webbing into her foot
and the jerk had snapped her neck now of
course depending on who you talked to
the green goblin was actually the one
that killed her because in the comic he
was like she was already dead before he
got here but the important thing here is
that it was a catastrophic failure of
spider-man if you take that and then you
put it in this movie and it's basically
the death of gwen stacy gives us this
dark and this just this this version of
spider-man that has essentially fallen
from grace it totally completes the
significance of gwen stacy's death
because the reality is with that movie
you never really saw how he came to
terms with it you saw him struggling
with it but you never saw how he came to
terms with it it was just like damn good
stacey died that sucks man the world's a
bleep place roll credits that was it
that's all you really got and so adding
that in giving us this third movie that
builds on that and shows us that darker
side of andrew would be phenomenal at
the same time once you get around to the
point where you would normally get the
climax right the point where he fights
the villain and the day is saved right
instead you basically get that scene in
the alleyway because here's the funny
thing about this i don't know how many
of you guys spotted this in the scene in
spider-man no way home when ned leeds
opens the portal due to the arbitrary
need for marvel to give him magic and
that in turn you see uh andrew garfield
standing out there in the alleyway that
scene where andrew garfield's standing
there that's the scene for the comics
when peter parker was gonna quit after
gwen stacy died right the spider-man no
more storyline it was this huge you know
massive storyline literally the cover of
the story like you guys probably seen
the cover of the story is peter walking
with his hands in his pockets hunched
over and his spider-man suit thrown in a
trash can right it was a landmark story
that's where that's from and so all you
really do here is you say okay that was
the moment when andrew was gonna quit
because that's the moment when he killed
a guy now that would be a pretty
controversial thing right like
spider-man killing a guy yes it's not
that far beyond the realm of possibility
to believe that could happen with andrew
becoming that much darker and it comes
from multiple places right i mean if
we're talking about toby mcguire
spider-man from the early 2000s sure
that's not really going to happen but
we're in an age of comic book movies now
where literally thanos showed up on on
earth took the last of the infinity
stones and blinked out half the life in
the universe we're in an age where
deadpool movies make light of killing
people
right it's not that uncommon to see
circumstances where either innocent
people are killed due to the collateral
damage of heroes and villains fighting
and they just don't talk about it right
like any of the moments from the entire
avengers film and the battle with the
chitauri it's a hard sell to convince me
no one innocent died in that entire
battle of new york it's just no one
discusses it right it just kind of gets
swept under the rug and we we know it
happens but nobody really brings it to
anybody's attention right or you've got
deadpool anti-hero movies where he makes
light of killing people or you've just
got straight up brutal situations where
thanos shows up and wipes out half the
life of the universe right so death is a
common theme
in the comic book movies that exist out
there these days and so when you look at
stories like superior spider-man right
dr octopus takes over the body of peter
parker gets into a fight with scorpion
and then knocks his jaw off his face and
comes to the realization holy [ __ ] like
spider-man could have killed any of us
in one punch at any point in time then
you realize peter was pulling his
punches all that time it's not that hard
to believe that he could do that right
then you look at something like spider
shadow where he actually kills people is
entirely possible right it's not outside
the realm of possibility but i'm
digressing the important thing here is
that in that moment right when he's
standing in that alleyway after he kills
a guy and he's like done that's it
enough right i've gone too far here the
portal opens behind him right and that's
that's all you get from spiderman no way
home you don't get anything else because
we know what happens right i mean
literally like like he goes to the
portal and he's like yeah man i've kind
of been walking around here in this new
version of new york i don't really know
what's going on um i got a reuben on rye
while i was here you know and it was as
good as i was expecting a reuben on rye
to be in the city of new york you know
it was amazing but like it's not like he
was doing a whole bunch of stuff right
you know well i i went to san francisco
and did some crazy things and like he
was there for like a few moments and
then got and then walked to the portal
and then he was hanging out with ned
leeds and mj right so close that scene
and then it's like a few seconds the
portal opens back up and the reason why
i think that works is because it's this
drastic juxtaposition when he goes
through the portal he's giving up he's
quitting he's done he's had enough of
being spider-man he's become this just
ridiculously dark version of spider-man
when he comes back out he's hopeful and
we as the audience having seen
spider-man no way home connect the dots
that we realize him coming out of that
portal is him with a new lease on life
right he's hopeful now more hopeful than
he's been in a long long time go forward
where he hangs out with sally field aunt
may who i think is still alive in those
movies i can't remember off top in my
head maybe a few other scenes that
illustrate the fact that it's hopeful
and he's standing at the top of his
favorite building in the city of new
york as the sun rises on a grateful
universe like you know what i mean like
like that kind of a thing you know so
again i think it would be it would be a
movie that doesn't really need a
traditional villain i mean do you need
to have villains sure if for no other
reason than to show us just how far he's
falling and how fast it's happening but
i think that the main villain of that
movie is not somebody like like
chameleon or or their version of morbius
or something like that it's andrew
garfield and that when that movie ends
it's andrew garfield getting back to
being the better spider-man getting back
to being the one that is trying to
become as great as tom holland was and
the best of them which is toby mcguire
right he just kind of rides off into the
sunset and the movie just kind of leaves
you on the film equivalent of letting
your voice trail off where you know and
then he lived happily ever after right
that kind of a thing right and then
that's it right just roll credits you
know and even if the movie was just kind
of like yeah it was okay it's his final
film right so like we as comic book
movie fans would look at that and see i
mean could the movie even better sure
but it's this final film so we'll all
just kind of silently agree to let the
bad parts go we'll stand up give him a
round of applause so you did a great job
andrew garfield and that'll be the end
of it right and they'll all finally get
their trilogies right he'll finally get
his third film we'll all celebrate
champagne will fall from the heavens
velvet robes will part for those of you
guys who ever watch gone in 60 seconds
and like that'll be it so let me know
what you guys think down in the comment
section about this idea right just kind
of something i've been mulling around
for the last few days but thank you guys
for watching hopefully i won't sound as
nasally because you know getting over
the flu the first week of the new year
is still something that i'm trying to do
and i will catch you all later
peace